You must have had this conversation when
you were a kid at some point where where
you or somebody says, "Hey, like why
don't we just make more money? Why don't
we just print more money? Give everybody
more money. Why don't we just do that?"
People have confused money for real
resources. And I think I think we live
in an age where like money is kind of
the new religion. And people confuse
money for real resources. And this is
like this confusion really prevents
people from seeing, you know,
seeing the forest in front of their
eyes. So co we knew the government was
going to give a trillion pounds out
which it did trillion pounds a lot of
money right 20 grand per person US
numbers even bigger you should know
distribution is going to change probably
inflation crisis probably a big increase
in asset prices it should be obvious
right because you printed tons of money
you haven't done anything to real
resources but what was the media
actually saying the media was saying oh
my god people have got so much money now
we're going to have such an economic
boom
when we reopen.